- (piano music)
- [Women Speaker] Air
pollution consists of chemicals
or particles in the
atmosphere, that pose serious
health and environmental threats.
But what causes air pollution?
And what does it mean for our planet?
Some air pollution comes
from natural sources,
like volcanic eruptions,
wild fires, or allergens.
But most air pollution
results from human activities.
Such as energy used in agriculture.
There are different types
of human-made air pollution.
When we burn fossil fuels to
produce energy they release
greenhouse gasses into the air.
This emissions such as
carbon dioxide, methane,
nitrous oxide and
fluorinated gasses trap heat
from the sun in earth's atmosphere.
Leading to a rise in global temperatures.
This creates a cycle where air pollution
contributes to climate change.
And climate change creates
higher temperatures.
In turn, higher temperatures intensifies
some types of air pollution.
For example, climate
change increases smog,
because it forms in the
presence of high heat
and increased levels of
ultraviolet radiation.
More frequent extreme
weather, such as flooding,
contributes to damp conditions
and therefore a rise in mold.
Warmer weather also leads
to longer pollen seasons,
and therefore more pollen production.
Smog, is a type of air pollution,
that reduces visibility
and has serious health effects.
Smog can be divided into two categories;
sulfurous and photochemical.
Sulfurous smog is made up of chemical
compounds called sulfur oxides.
It occurs when burning
sulfur baring fossil
fuels, such as coal.
Photochemical smog, also
called ground level ozone,
is a result of the
reaction between sunlight,
and nitrogen oxides, and
volatile organic compounds.
Nitrogen oxides come from car exhaust,
coal power plants, and factory emissions.
Volatile organic compounds
are released from
gasoline, paints, and
many cleaning solvents.
Smog not only creates a brown
haze that reduces visibility,
but also harms plants, irritates
the eyes, and causes respiratory distress.
Another category of air
pollution is toxic pollutants.
These are chemicals such
as mercury, lead, dioxins,
and benzine that are released
during gas or coal combustion,
waste incineration, or
burning of gasoline.
In addition to adverse
environmental effects,
toxic air pollution can cause
serious health problems.
Such as cancer,
reproductive complications,
and birth defects.
While air pollution has many consequences
for our planet, there are solutions.
We can limit toxic pollutes,
smog and greenhouse gases,
by decreasing the use of fossil fuels.
Such as in transportation, manufacturing,
and electricity generation.
Reducing air pollution, not
only contributes to a cleaner
environment, and better human
health, but can also slow the
rate of global warming.
(chime music)